we begin in Sudan where citizens and
foreigners are trying to escape the
fighting between the Army and the
parametry rapid support forces more than
1 600 people of various nationalities
arrived in Jeddah Saudi Arabia overnight
it comes after yet another ceasefire has
been repeatedly violated the
humanitarian situation has been
deteriorating fast since violence broke
out 12 days ago
Heber Morgan is live for us in Khartoum
so with prices rising situation becoming
even more desperate now Heather
yes indeed for many people they say that
the situation has become untenable but
they can't leave the capital because
they lack the financial means to do so
and this is the second day of a
ceasefire that is supposed to be holding
and yet some residents say they can hear
the sounds of artillery strikes here in
the central part of the capital hotel we
can hear heavy artillery shellings
we just heard another one and so it
looks like the second day of ceasefire
also appears to be shaky now that was a
similar scene on the first day as well
they were parts of the capital where it
was quiet and there were other parts
where there were an exchange of gunfire
between the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Army where it was quiet
residents say they try to do their best
to leave to leave the capital
residents of Khartoum try to escape on
the first day of a 72-hour ceasefire
announced by the wearing sides they'd
been caught up amid heavy bombardment
for 11 days now they're faced with other
difficulties in trying to leave the
scarcity of fuel has made it hard even
to reach bus stations the cost of
transportation to other cities has
skyrocketed those who have cash
are getting out heading to the Egyptian
border
go up trying to see if they can get to
the Ethiopian border and whatever but
there's a lot of many hundreds thousands
of other Sudanese who don't have that
luxury and I don't know what they're
going to do the poor majority who can't
leave are the most exposed
we are really suffering to begin with
fuels have run out bakeries are closed
and we cannot find a loaf of bread the
same for meat prices have soared one
kilo of tomatoes cost nearly nine
dollars let alone the sharp shortage of
medicines we cannot live here or even
leave to other areas we call on the
government to do something to end this
war at least to allow us to flee and
despite the U.S brokered humanitarian
ceasefire the fighting has continued in
parts of the Sudanese Capital Khartoum
and elsewhere in umderman a shell landed
in a roomy Hospital wounding over a
dozen people including patients and
medical staff a roomy hospital is the
latest in the capital to be hit by
artillery forcing its closure and adding
to a worsening situation its patients
were evacuated to a nearby medical
facility that was already dealing with
an influx of people injured from nearly
two weeks of fighting
ending the war is not what the two
wearing sides meant by the ceasefire its
aim according to the warring parties is
to allow citizens and residents to
access health care or move to Safe zones
while foreign Nationals are being
evacuated but while those foreign
Nationals are being taken to the safety
of their own homes abroad these Sudanese
are being forced to leave theirs
humanitarian impact of this crisis will
be harsh before this crisis Sudan hosted
more than 1 million refugees and 3.7
million were internally displaced the UN
says at least 20 000 Sudanese refugees
have arrived in Chad and on Sudan's
border with Ethiopia a similar scene
Sudanese civilians and Nationals from up
to 23 countries all desperate to leave
what can you tell us about President
Bashir era officials who've escaped
well at least four prominent members of
former president bushiri's uh government
and ruling party have escaped covert
prison that's in the northern part of
the capital Khartoum now this happened
on the 23rd which was on a Sunday and
many people wondered where they were
including where the former president is
now we know from his family that he's
safe and he's in the military Hospital
not part of the people who escaped from
the prison but those prisoners are not
just any ordinary prisoners they include
Ahmed harun who's wanted by the
international criminal court for the war
crimes and crimes against humanity in
the western region of Darfur that Wars
obviously started in the in 2003 and
went on up to 2018 but he released an
audio statement saying that once the
fighting is over he will hand himself to
the judicial authorities to be tried now
the Sudanese Army also released a
statement saying that the prisons fell
under the direct supervision and control
of the Interior Ministry and that it's
their job to protect prisoners but the
interior ministry right now is being
occupied by the rapid support forces so
this is adding to the care
all right we'll leave you there thanks
so much Kevin Morgan
our former Sudanese Minister who's
wanted by the international criminal
court for war crimes has escaped from
that prison in Khartoum Ahmed Haroon
released an audio statement commenting
on the conflict
I address you today as our country is
living a dire situation unprecedented in
its modern history I confirmed that I'm
standing on your side to safeguard our
homeland from being hijacked by tribal
agenda backed by some Regional and
international States our homeland is
above any political agenda or partisan
entity or any political interest in our
countrymen and woman's blood cannot be
the price paid for any conflict for
power here I reiterate the same
sentiment strongly despite the
oppression and Injustice done by the
perpetrators of April 2019 coup who have
kept us in confinement duplicate
Regional and international Powers which
are now proven to be the arch enemy to
the Sudanese people
tens of thousands of people have fled
the fighting Al Jazeera journalist
Mohammed Tawakal is following The Exodus
on the Sudan Ethiopia border
we're standing at this point on the
Sudan Ethiopia border
only a 10 minute long bridge separates
the two countries
people have started to flock to this
area because it's the only land border
crossing from Sudan into Ethiopia more
than 2 000 people from 23 different
countries have managed to reach the
Ethiopian border
as you can see they have come to the
small Border Town most of them can get
an entry Visa upon arrival
this border crossing used to process a
dozen or more people in the past but now
the numbers are in the thousands
the situation here is dire this small
town cannot handle such a huge influx of
people
some countries acted quickly such as
turkey which transported 1 000 Turkish
citizens on Monday alone the majority of
those behind me are also Turkish
citizens others like syrians and yemenis
cannot get a visa on arrival
authorities here are trying to find
Solutions a large number of Sudanese
have also come to this Crossing
transportation to this point May cost up
to one thousand dollars
U.N Secretary General Antonio Gutierrez
is calling on Sudan's warring parties to
silence the guns he says the conflict
will not be resolved on the battlefield
our diplomatic editor James Bays has the
story
in its first open meeting on Sudan since
the crisis started the security Council
received a dismal picture of the
situation inside the country with the
U.N Secretary General telling them
violence could soon spread these 10 days
of violence
and Chaos are heartbreaking
a prolonged full-scale war is unbearable
to contemplate
Sudan border seven countries all of
which have either been involved in
conflicts or sincere civil unrest over
the past decade
it is a gateway to the sale where
insecurity and political instability are
making an already catastrophic
humanitarian situation even worse the
secretary General's special
representative for Sudan was recently
relocated from Khartoum joining an 800
kilometer Overland Convoy to Port Sudan
from where he briefed the council so two
generals continue trading accusations
and issuing competing claims of control
over key installations
there is yet no unequivocal sign that
either is ready to seriously negotiate
suggesting that both think that securing
a military victory over the other is
possible
this is a miscalculation
for now the security Council has been
unable to agree a further statement on
Sudan there are plenty of things they
could do they could accuse the two rival
generals of war crimes even put
sanctions on them but they know the
International Community for now must
continue to deal with both men to try
and keep the patchy ceasefires
continuing James Bay's Al Jazeera of the
United Nations
meanwhile Sudan's ambassador to the U.N
is calling on the rapid support forces
to lay down their weapons and integrate
into the army
I do not need physical evidence to prove
the scale of the damages and suffering
from this Rebellion but despite all of
the above Sudan remains a United State
assuming its functions with
responsibility we did not declare a
state of emergency the events have not
had a regional spillover Sudan will
defeat these difficult circumstances we
hope to end the rebellion and recall on
the council to understand the
exceptionally urgent situation and Grant
Sudan the time it needs to come up with
adequate opportunities to achieve
positive progress that would bring Sudan
to a better position and revive the
demands of the Revolution Freedom peace
and justice